i feel bad that you know this whole
relationship with you guys i'm talking
about
stills and nash and young i know the
whole past history with uh why each of
you are not talking to one another those
three are talking to each other they're
not talking to you
it just seems you know it's time to let
go of that and that it was kind of
snotty
i i i said well we talked to each other
but none of us talked to him
which is not true i do talk to stephen
uh you do
neil yeah neil's got a a legitimate beef
because i i dissed his girlfriend i get
it i apologize for it
with you uh you helped me do that that
was very kind of you
uh nash is kind of uh
seems to think that i'm responsible for
everything wrong since the korean war
uh which is weird but that's okay uh
whatever makes him happy uh stills i got
a lot of hero worship for stills man he
was
the best guy in the band he's the best
guitar player
the best singer and wrote all the hits
and was
stunning on stage just stunning man
every time the guy touches a guitar
everything swings right away i miss i
have no beef with any of them man i hope
they're all okay
uh i want them to be you know happy
i i am a little surprised that
that uh they're not you know putting out
music but i don't know whatever they're
doing i hope they're happy
i'm surprised that graham and you
i mean i don't know i feel like you guys
are almost brothers
you know i'm talking i did too man i it
came as a kind of a shock to me but
you know he blew it pretty badly with me
and
man uh he's said a bunch of really awful
stuff
you know in the book uh so i
i don't know i i'm not never say never
but i'm not worried about it
i'm not i don't concern myself with it i
don't think about him or
neil or i do think about stephen pretty
often have you reached out and
no no no all of that drama stuff man
it's just
a pain in the butt and it doesn't make
music what i worry about as we all
approach
the end of our lives here as we get
older it would be really sad
if one of you went and and and there
wasn't some sort of reconciliation
i don't think it's in the cards
i i haven't sensed it from any uh either
of those guys and
i've really truthfully men my head is in
today
my head is in what i'm doing i love that
i love it
i wish they would be happy don't i don't
i'm not looking for
them to absolve me of my idiocy you
understand man i let all three of those
guys down
totally by becoming a junkie that was
that's where i really did hurt them
not just dissing their girlfriend or
pissing them off
i actually did harm uh
and for that you know i've apologized a
million times and and the best apology i
could make was to
beat it and come up and be useful again
so i'm fine
you mean you did harm to the business in
other words you made their lives
i did harm to the group you know i
pretty much destroyed it right then
and we did put it back together again
when i got sober but
it's i certainly you know hurt
all three of those guys we all three
hurt each other over and over again
all of us did horrible stuff to each
other neil's leaving stephen in the
middle of a door
right leaving in the middle of a tour
leaving before monterey
we we did a lot of bad stuff to each
other
it's history you know they're gonna do a
huge documentary on csn you know about
that right
no i don't where are they doing that
nigel sinclair
and tim sexton are producing a another
uh
huge doctor documentary this one on csn
is going to be directed by uh
robert zemeckis so how david how can
they do that
without the three of you guys getting in
the same room together
uh they're gonna have to really there's
ten thousand hours of footage man that's
true
no lack of stuff to work with uh
right and we'll do interviews for it you
know i i i had a really good talk with
the director
uh uh semancus is a very
very very smart guy and
uh he understands the situation and the
lay of the land quite well
and we'll see how it all plays out